all smiles for their return to europe
together after two years in the
netherlands ahead of the start of the
invictus games the duke and duchess of
sussex soak up all that they'd left
behind
since their californian move there's
been the arrival of now 10 month old
lillabet new business ventures and that
explosive oprah interview
it's perhaps why they made a surprise
visit to see her majesty yesterday at
windsor castle away from prying eyes the
low-key return a big contrast to the
dramatic exit
it's obviously a huge rift in their
family they did that tell-all interview
and it was very very explosive and they
were clearly angry and hurt at the time
well she wouldn't do something like that
but then over time feelings do mellow i
think when it comes to their motives i
think of course it looks good for them
to have met with the queen because that
shows that something is healing in that
rift
the visit came as prince charles and
camilla attended the maundy thursday
service in the castle grounds an event
the queen chose to pull out of due to
ongoing mobility issues it's understood
he was also reunited with his youngest
son that day a much needed face-to-face
family reunion perhaps to mend the
challenging time apart
but some are skeptical of the timing
because they're going to be doing this
documentary for netflix
it's not a compassionate
visit it's not a visit because there is
them
i think it's um something that will be
useful
because they can
say something about the visit to the
queen
and prince charles
the stateside couple are documenting
their journey to this year's invictus
games founded by the prince the
competition for injured veterans is
where the duo made their first public
appearance together five years ago
now they've chosen it to make their
comeback ashnaharanag sky news in the
hague